I'm very very glad that I'm not a female
trying to navigate the world of female
friendships to me seems unbelievably
difficult is it right to say that female
friendships are more complex than male
friendships do you think I think so I've
become increasingly interested in how
women form Cooperative relationships and
the Cooperative part I also find very
interesting because they're intertwined
tying into Joyce bennetson's work yeah
she's found that competition tends to
corrode female relationships more than
men's men can more easily return to
cooperation following competition then
can women she finds it in little kids
she finds it in adult athletes for
female relationships they tend to
dissolve if there's more competition in
it and in fact I think if anything it
seems like there can be a positive
aspect to competing with your male
friends there's just so much more overt
interactions happening in male same-sex
relationships whereas for women's it
seems to be a lot more kind of under the
surface all these dynamics that are
happening that aren't explicitly
acknowledged